[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend ihnen wir beginnen mit einer
historischen Leistung an der
Generationen von Forscherinnen und
Forschern gegrübelt haben einem Labor in
den USA ist jetzt ein Durchbruch
gelungen bei der Kernfusion mehr Energie
gewinnen als man dafür einsetzen muss
das ist der alte Menschheitstraum der
unsere Welt in einigen Jahren
grundlegend verändern könnte sie merken
schon da ist er der Konjunktiv denn ob
wir so wirklich klimaneutral und sicher
Strom erzeugen werden können ob das
tatsächlich die Lösung aller
Energieprobleme ist da stellen sich noch
viele Fragen auf der anderen Seite gilt
gerade hier und jetzt der Satz von
Friedrich Schiller wer nichts Bargeld
der darf nichts hoffen wenn ihr mir
Daniel berichtet
15 Millionen Grad heiß ist die Sonne in
ihrem Kern die Energie die sie auf
unsere Erde strahlt ist ein
Tausendfaches dessen was wir Menschen
eigentlich brauchen was da oben in
diesem für uns so wichtigen Stern
passiert ist nun erstmals auch hier
unten auf der Erde gelungen
[Musik]
wasserstoffatomkerne verschmelzen und
werden zu Helium dabei wird mehr Energie
freigesetzt als verbraucht Forschern ist
das in einem Labor in Kalifornien mit
Hilfe von Laserbestrahlung gelungen
der Sonne die ja ohnehin schon die
meiste Energie für uns liefert genau
diese Mechanik versucht die Wissenschaft
hier auf der Erde zu reproduzieren und
die wenigen Rohstoffe die man dafür
braucht können aus einfachem Meerwasser
gewonnen werden
die
us-energieministerin spricht von einem
historischen Durchbruch
dieser Meilenstein bringt uns einen
riesigen Schritt näher an die
Möglichkeit heran unsere Gesellschaft
mit komplett CO2 freier fusions Energie
zu versorgen
Kernfusion gegen Klimawandel laut der
Ministerin könnte der Forschungserfolg
unser heutiges Energiemodell
revolutionieren
wenn wir diese Technologie
weiterentwickeln können wir damit
saubere Elektrizität produzieren sie als
Treibstoff Nutzen in der Schwerindustrie
einsetzen und so vieles mehr es ist so
als würden wir einen Schlagbohrer
hinzufügen zu unserer Werkzeugkiste im
Kampf für eine saubere Wirtschaft
was auf den ersten Blick
vielversprechend klingt hat allerdings
noch einen Haken noch muss zu viel
Energie investiert werden denn riesige
Mengen Laserstrahlen müssen dafür in
einen zylindergeschossen werden dort
verdichtet sich dann die Energie zu
gezielter Röntgenstrahlung sie bringt am
Ende eine Kapsel mit Wasserstoff zur
Zündung bei der mehr Energie frei wird
als der Strahl mitbringt gewinnen nur in
diesem letzten Schritt etwa ein Drittel
um den Prozess zu starten ist also ein
riesiger Energieaufwand nötig dieses
Problem zu lösen wird wohl noch
Jahrzehnte dauern es hat einen Schritt
auf einem langen Weg man kann auch nicht
direkt diese Methode benutzen für einen
Kraftwerk und man muss das ganze dann 20
Mal pro Sekunde machen und das ist schon
noch ein langer Weg aber ist halt ein
Schritt auf diesem Weg zu einem
fusionskraft eine kurzfristige Lösung
unserer Energieprobleme verspricht das
gelungene Experiment also nicht auf die
lange Strecke aber könnte der Griff nach
den Sternen gelingen und für die
Menschheit vieles verändern
die Kernfusion hat das Potenzial mehr
Menschen weltweit aus der Armut zu
befreien als die Erfindung des Feuers
sagt der Vorsitzende des Ausschusses für
Fusionsenergie im US-Parlament was für
ein Satz
Bundesforschungsministerin Bettina stark
Watzinger als bei uns guten Abend Frau
Ministerin sind sie heute auch vor
Begeisterung an die Decke gesprungen
guten Abend Herr Sievers ja heute ist
ein historischer Tag Forscherinnen und
Forscher haben sich gegen alle Bedenken
durchgesetzt und haben das erstmal die
Sonne auf die Erde geholt und somit also
auch eine neue Möglichkeit der
Energieversorgung verlässlich
klimaneutral uns erschlossen zumindest
den Weg dahin erschlossen insofern ein
historischer Tag und ich danke allen
Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern dieser Tag braucht noch
viel weitere Forschung und vor allem
viel Geld der US-Staat hat bereits
Milliarden bereitgestellt US-Unternehmen
alleine im letzten Jahr in die Forschung
nach Energie aus Kernfusion fast 3
Milliarden Dollar investiert was macht
in Deutschland wir müssen mit unseren
wertepartnern weltweit Forschung ist
international zusammenarbeiten wir haben
Stärken auch in der Kernfusionsforschung
wir sind da technologieoffen wie sich
überhaupt zeigt dass wir
technologieoffen die großen
Herausforderungen mit Innovation
bekämpfen können insofern ein
europäischer Schulterschluss und vor
allen Dingen der Wettbewerb
Forschungsinstitutionen Start-ups
Wettbewerb der Technologien das ist die
Zukunft und wir werden schnell
Fortschritte sehen können das klingt
jetzt erstmal gut man merkt auch sie
sind da voll dahinter aber was konkret
können Sie denn da versprechen außer
jetzt der Ankündigung dass das eine gute
Sache ist und wir da investieren sollten
ja wir werden natürlich auch in unserer
Forschungsstrategie die Zukunftsenergien
und dazu gehört die Kernfusion ganz
bestimmt weiter unsere Anstrengung
intensivieren und Forscherinnen und
Forscher unterstützen wie gesagt zum
einen die Forschungseinrichtung die wir
haben aber auch die Möglichkeiten
eröffnen für die Start-ups die auch
durch ihre Agilität noch mal dazu
beitragen dass wir neue Erkenntnisse
auch schnell umsetzen aber was heißt
denn Möglichkeiten eröffnen heißt das
sie stecken da jetzt auch Milliarden
rein wie ihre amerikanischen Kollegen
wir werden natürlich mit den
europäischen Partnern auch eine hohe
Summe investieren das ist ganz klar
Forschung ist eine staatliche Aufgabe
aber es geht auch um Schulterschluss
zwischen Forschungen und Industrie wenn
wir Kernfusionsreaktoren bauen wollen
dann müssen wir hier den Schulterschluss
suchen und die Zusammenarbeit und das
ist etwas was wir auch schon können und
was zukunftsweisend ist und das wird die
Aufgabe im nächsten Jahr sein es ist ein
bisschen der Tag an dem man sich große
Ziele steckt vielleicht auch ein
bisschen träumen darf wann wird das
erste deutsche
Fusionskraftwerk ans Netz gehen was
würden Sie sagen also das ist ja unser
sunshot-projekt diese Kernfusion weil
wir dann eben schaffen Energie als Basis
für den Wohlstand wirklich verlässlich
und günstig auch zur Verfügung zu
stellen insofern die Ambition dürfen da
nicht zu klein sein ich sage zehn Jahre
als kann auch etwas länger dauern aber
wir müssen uns die Ambitionen ja setzen
die Bundesforschungsministerin ich danke
Ihnen ganz herzlich für das Gespräch ich
danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch mit Bettina stark
Watzinger haben wir kurz vor dieser
Sendung aufgezeichnet jetzt aus der
Vision von einer Zukunft in der wichtige
Probleme gelöst wären zurück in die
Gegenwart mit ihrem Schrecken der Winter
als Waffe Terror gegen eine frierende
Zivilbevölkerung die russischen Angriffe
haben etwa die Hälfte der
Energieinfrastruktur in der Ukraine
beschädigt es ist dunkel geworden und
kalt in Kiew und deshalb
Frankreichs Präsident Emmanuel macron
hat heute dutzende Länder und
internationale Organisationen nach Paris
geladen es ist die mittlerweile sechste
geber-konferenz für die Ukraine
versprochen werden Lieferungen von
Lebensmitteln und Generatoren und viel
Geld die bisherigen Erfahrungen
allerdings zeigen versprechen lässt sich
viel wirklich gezahlt wurde bisher
deutlich weniger und dabei können die
Menschen bei eisigem Frost nicht länger
warten wie eine Brillen
Licht dass die Dunkelheit erhält an kaum
einem Ort fehlt das so wie in rakev das
Friedenslicht aus Bethlehem ist im
Bahnhof der Stadt angekommen mitten im
Luftalarm
wieder einmal steht in der Stadt alles
still
mit der Weihnachtsaktion der Pfadfinder
verbinden Alina und Victoria große
Hoffnung
wir wollen Segen wie alle anderen so
einfach ist das und Frieden Gesundheit
und Erfolg für unsere Soldaten
das wäre gut wenn der Krieg bald vorbei
wäre wir hoffen sehr darauf wir wollen
das dieses Feuer ist ein Symbol dafür
dass wir am Leben sind dass die Ukraine
lebt
welche Kraft das kostet auch das sieht
man in hakiff überall Baustellen gerade
reparieren sie 40 Wohnblocks die bei
russischen Angriffen schwer beschädigt
wurden
alle arbeiten parallel die Installateure
arbeiten jetzt an der Heizung im
Dachgeschoss
wurde aber er glaubt dass es weitere
Blackouts durch die Russen geben wird
wollen wir wissen
ich denke ja
die gezielte Zerstörung der
Infrastruktur Häuser ohne Strom Heizung
Wasser es ist das was alle beschäftigt
denn auch in intakten Gebäuden wird die
Versorgung geplant unterbrochen manchmal
bis zu sieben Stunden am Tag
in der Schule 122 findet schon lange
kein Unterricht mehr statt gekocht wird
trotzdem für alle die das Zuhause nicht
mehr können die Stadt bezahlt
heute gibt es zum Mittagessen Borscht
mit Bohnen Hirsebrei mit büchsenfleisch
und Kakao
wie eine Decke legt sich ab 16 Uhr die
Dunkelheit über hakiff im Bezirk seit
tiefgeist das besonders heftig nur
wenige Wohnungen sind noch bewohnbar
nata und ihr Mann nehmen uns mit in den
fünften Stock das Licht funktioniert
gerade auch die Heizung Angst vor dem
Winter haben sie trotzdem
wenn wir genügend Gas haben dann können
wir es ertragen aber wenn wir kein Gas
und keinen Strom mehr haben
Nathan klingt entschlossener als ihr
Mann
ich hasse Putin ich hasse ihn so sehr
dass ich überleben werde trotz alledem
weitermachen irgendwie manchmal reicht
ihnen schon ein Licht in der Dunkelheit
ein Licht in der Dunkelheit Millionen
davon sind nötig Murat Sahin ist Leiter
von UNICEF in der Ukraine erst seit
Februar vor Ort in Kiew fashion schönen
guten Abend
hi hallo guten Abend aus haben Sie denn
den Eindruck sie werden der Not im
Moment noch her
jeden Tag wird es immer schwieriger für
uns für die humanitären Arbeiter die
sich für die Kinder einsetzt in der
Ukraine es gibt vier Millionen von
Kindern in der Ukraine deren Leben
völlig durcheinander ist und jeden Tag
wird aber komplizierter für die Kinder
es ist sehr schwierig ein Kind zu sein
in der Ukraine und das ist schwierig
Elternteil zu sein oder Mutter zu sein
können Sie uns vielleicht kurz
beschreiben wie die Situation ist ohne
Strom ohne Wärme wie trifft das die
Eltern die Kinder im Moment
Anfang September mit dem Beginn des
Schuljahres habe gesagt okay eine
Infrastruktur die digital ist da können
die Kinder nicht zur Schule gehen weil
die Schulen beschädigt sind mehr als
2000 Schulen wollen die am Anfang des
Krieges schon beschädigt und wir haben
gesagt okay mit einer Hybridform können
in Verbindung bleiben mit den Kindern
digital aber jetzt gibt's keinen Strom
mehr denn nur zwei drei Stunden vier
Stunden in verschiedene Städten gibt es
zwei Strom das ist schwierig für die
Kinder mit ihren Freunden in Kontakt zu
kommen mit ihren Lehrern und es ist
schwierig weiterhin zu lernen während
dieser Zeit und als Mutter ist es auch
sehr schwierig daran tausend Kinder
werden geboren und alle zwei Minuten ein
Kind geboren und stellen sich mal vor
sie werden so eine Welt hineingeboren
und sie wollen gebären in deinem
Krankenhaus im Krankenhaus gibt es
keinen Strom man braucht ja für die
Krankenhäuser Strom für die Schulen man
braucht Wasser Heizung und in Kiew haben
wir jetzt minus ein Grad in der Nacht
stellt sich vor mit Häusern ohne Strom
ohne Wasser ohne Heizung das ist
wirklich hart jetzt haben wir heute eine
weitere internationale geber-konferenz
wie sehen Sie das direkt vor Ort hilft
Geld oder müssen die geber-staaten ganz
neu denken und gerade angesichts der
Lage die sie beschreiben viel mehr in
Logistik in Gerät in Generatoren
investieren
viel getan werden zunächst mal Frieden
jedes Kind braucht Frieden es ist
schwierig ein Kind zu sein in diesem
Land in dieser Kriegssituation die
Geberländer
die geben großzügig für Gesundheit für
Sorge Krankenhäuser Zugang zu Wasser und
normalen Diensten
allein können das Problem nicht lösen
15.000 Schulen 5000 Krankenhäuser
ausgeliefert werden
die in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
geliefert werden aber das reicht einfach
nicht man kann Generatoren
die funktioniert mit großen
Generator um Wasser zu liefern aber das
ist nicht die Lösung wir brauchen
Frieden Frieden für jedes Kind
solange es keinen Frieden gibt und wie
sie ja gerade beschreiben die Lage auch
mit sehr vielen Hilfslieferungen kommen
noch in den Griff zu bekommen ist wie
lang ist das überhaupt noch auszuhalten
anders gefragt wird es eine neue eine
weitere große Zahl von Menschen geben
die einfach fliehen müssen wir zeigen
wir tun was wir können aber wir wissen
nicht wohin die Leute sich bewegen
werden es gibt immer stärkere Bewegungen
von Menschen aber es ist wichtig sicher
zu stellen dass wir irgendwie zufrieden
kommen so dass die Kinder das bekommen
was Sie brauchen vor allem brauchen sie
jetzt Frieden
sagt Murat Sahin der Leiter des
Kinderhilfswerks der Vereinten Nationen
UNICEF in Kiew Herr Schahin ganz
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch heute
Abend
das Gespräch etwas technischen Gründen
vor einer halben Stunde aufgezeichnet
der Überblick in Kurzform jetzt über
vieles was noch wichtig ist heute bei
Diana wer eine Öl oder Pelletheizung hat
soll nun angesichts der gestiegenen
Preise ebenfalls entlastet werden das
hat die Ampelkoalition beschlossen pro
Haushalt soll es maximal 2000 € geben
und zwar rückwirkend für den Zeitraum
vom 1 januar bis zum 1 dezember 2022
insgesamt stellt der Bund dafür 1,8
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung die
Auszahlung sollen die Bundesländer
organisieren
bei einer Razzia in sechs Bundesländern
hat die Polizei Wohnungen von
klimaaktivisten der letzten Generation
durchsucht Hintergrund sind mehrere
Aktionen gegen die Raffinerie PCK
Schwedt wie hier im Mai dabei hatten
sich Aktivisten an einer Anlage geklebt
und zeitweise die Ölzufuhr unterbrochen
die Staatsanwaltschaft Neuruppin wirft
ihnen die Störung öffentlicher Betriebe
vor und ermittelt außerdem wegen des
Verdachts der Bildung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung
der rechtsextreme Attentäter von Halle
hat am Montagabend in einem
Hochsicherheitsgefängnis nah Magdeburg
zwei Geiseln genommen die beiden
Justizbeamten konnten nach kurzer Zeit
wieder befreit werden 2019 hatte der
Mann versucht schwer bewaffnet in die
Synagoge von Halle einzudringen als in
dies nicht gelang erschoss er zwei
Menschen in der näheren Umgebung der
Täter wurde zu einer lebenslangen
Haftstrafe mit anschließender
Sicherungsverwahrung verurteilt
mehr als sechs Jahre nach dem
islamistischen Anschlag von Nizza hat
die französische Justiz achthelfer des
Attentäters schuldig gesprochen sieben
Männer und eine Frau wurden zu zwei bis
18 Jahren Haft für die Mitgliedschaft in
einer Terrorgruppe und die logistische
Unterstützung für den Attentäter
verurteilt bei den Feiern zum
französischen Nationalfeiertag 2016 war
der Attentäter mit einem Tonnen schweren
Lkw in die Menge gerast und gab auch
Schüsse ab 86 Menschen starben der
Attentäter wurde von der Polizei
erschossen
und jetzt eine Nachricht aus der Reihe
bis hierhin und nicht weiter die große
Mehrheit der EU-Staaten hatte ja schon
länger die Geduld verloren mit dem EU
Mitglied ungarn hatte größte Sorge das
Europas Gelder dort versickern weil die
Regierung zu wenig gegen Korruption
unternimmt nur Ungarns starker Mann
premier Viktor Orban konnte das locker
weglächeln weil es für ihn keine Folgen
hatte das Signal aus Brüssel nach
Budapest heißt jetzt die Zeit der
Straflosigkeit ist vorbei 6,3 Milliarden
Euro aus der Gemeinschaftskasse für
Ungarn sind erstmal blockiert vor allem
das Europaparlament hatte da jahrelang
den Druck erhöht dasselbe Parlament dass
sich gerade allerdings mit massiven
Korruptionsvorwürfen in den eigenen
Reihen herumschlägt ultra
Viktor Orban genießt die Rolle des
Provokateurs in der EU er steht oft
allein gegen die anderen in einem Tweet
macht er sich gestern noch genüsslich
über den
eu-korruptions-skandal lustig er der
selber kritisiert wird warf der EU
Scheinheiligkeit vor vielleicht war es
diese eine Provokation zu viel die das
fast zum überlaufen brachte er hat damit
gerechnet dass er am Ende doch nicht
alleinstehen wird das vielleicht die
Polen oder die Italiener gegen eine
solche Regelung sein werden weil sie ja
selbst auch befürchten dass angewandt
auf sie angewand zu bekommen aber er hat
sich insofern verzockt gestern Nacht in
Brüssel fällt eine historische
Entscheidung die EU-Mitglieder wollen
6,3 Milliarden Euro einfrieren weil sie
Angst haben dass Ungarn sie veruntrat
das zeigt eben auch dass diese Werte wie
Rechtsstaatlichkeit nicht verhandelbar
sind dass wir da klar dahinter stehen
ein Signal an ihn Viktor Orban der
ungarische Regierungschef verstößt gegen
die Werte der EU dafür haben ihn die
anderen Mitglieder abgestraft da wo es
ihn am meisten weh tut beim Geld ein
einmaliger
vorgangsspect natural ich glaube nicht
dass Ungarn den Kompromiss zustimmen
wird aber sonst steht die Mehrheit
lange war nicht klar ob die Mehrheit
steht Orban erpresste seine Kollegen er
drohte den Ukraine Hilfsprogramm nicht
zuzustimmen falls ein Land sanktioniert
wird unter anderem drohten die deutschen
zurück falls der Ungar dies mache würden
sie langfristig EU-Gelder blockieren
ich denke das ist auf jeden Fall ein ein
ganz wichtiger Schritt Europas gewesen
um Orban zu zeigen dass er mit seiner
veto-politik hier nicht durchkommt und
so werden nun EU-Mittel in Höhe von 6,3
Milliarden Euro für Ungarn blockiert
weitere Milliarden aus dem Corona Aufbau
von sind an das Erreichen von Reformen
beim Rechtsstaat angeknüpft auf der
anderen Seite stimmt Ungarn einer
EU-weiten Mindeststeuer von 15% für
Unternehmen zu und 18 Milliarden Euro
Finanzhilfe für die Ukraine
Justizministerin erklärt sofort die
Niederlage zum Triumph um nicht als
Verliererin darzustellen
was wir am Ende hinbekommen haben ist
ein gutes Ergebnis
und dann will sie schnell weg eigentlich
diese Frage nicht mehr beantworten die
EU hat Ungarn doch mit Sanktionen belegt
das sind keine Sanktionen sondern wir
haben eine Verabredung
eine Verabredung das Orban die
Korruption im Lande bekämpft sonst gibt
es kein Geld dass er so dringend für
seine Popularität braucht
[Musik]
so und damit sind wir noch mal bei Dir
ja und da blicken wir auf eine
Schlüsselfigur im cum-ex-skandal der
Anwalt hanno Berger ist vom Landgericht
Bonn zu einer Freiheitsstrafe von acht
Jahren verurteilt worden wegen besonders
schwerer Steuerhinterziehung der Schaden
für den Staat beträgt über 270 Millionen
Euro das Gericht entschied außerdem dass
Berger 13,7 Millionen Euro zurückzahlen
muss
2021 hatte der Bundesgerichtshof die
cum-ex-deals als Straftat eingestuft
die Inflation bleibt trotz eines
leichten Rückgangs im November weiterhin
hoch bei 10 Prozent das sind keine guten
Nachrichten für Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher es gibt allerdings auch
Profiteure der aktuellen Situation Frank
beetmann laut Ifo-Institut machen sich
viele Unternehmen die Lage zu Nutze um
gezielt ihre Gewinne zu maximieren was
steckt genau dahinter wir bekommen ja
alle mit dass auch für die Unternehmen
alles teurer wird die Kosten für Energie
und für Vorleistung und so haben wir
akzeptieren müssen dass auch die Preise
im Laden oder online deutlich gestiegen
sind doch sind die Preiserhöhungen auch
immer in vollem Umfang gerechtfertigt
diese Frage hat das Ifo-Institut
beschäftigt und so kommt Joachim Ragnitz
tatsächlich zum Ergebnis einige
Unternehmen scheinen den Kostenschub als
Vorwand dafür zu nehmen durch eine
Erhöhung ihrer Absatzpreise auch ihre
Gewinnsituation zu verbessern
insbesondere in der Land und
Forstwirtschaft und in den Branchen
Handel Gastgewerbe und Verkehr sowie im
Baugewerbe seit dass der Fall gewesen
Ragnitz nennt das gewinninflation
gleichzeitig schränkt der
Wirtschaftsforscher allerdings ein
hauptverantwortlich für die Teuerung
sein immer noch die tatsächliche
gestiegenen Kosten der Betriebe der DAX
verbessert sich heute deutlich um über
190 auf fast 14.500 Punkte und auch das
hat viel mit der Inflation zu tun die
ist nämlich in den USA deutlicher
zurückgegangen als erwartet was auch die
Börsianer heute
vielen Dank Frank für deine Einschätzung
am Morgen hat es einen unangekündigten
Warnstreik im ZDF gegeben das
Morgenmagazin viel aus genauso wie die
heute Express-Sendungen und die volle
Kanne die Gewerkschaften wer die Vrf und
DJV hatten dazu aufgerufen sie bemängeln
dass ich bei den laufenden
Tarifverhandlungen nicht genug bewege
die nächste Verhandlungsrunde ist am 21
Dezember
und jetzt der Blick direkt nach Katha
zum ersten Halbfinale dieser
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft seit wenigen
Minuten ist das Spiel Argentinien
Kroatien beendet und nun ist klar dass
die argentinia im Finale stehen der
sechsmalige Weltfußballer Lionel Messi
will bei seiner letzten WM endlich auch
Weltmeister werden und nach diesem faul
von Kroatiens livakowitschern julian
alvardes ist es Lionel Messi der
höchstpersönlich per Strafstoß für
Argentiniens 1:0 Führung sorgt der nur 5
Minuten später dieses Solo von Julian
alvaris folgt auf dem Weg zum 2:0 für
die aliss und die profitiert auch in der
zweiten Hälfte vom unaufhaltsamen Lionel
Messi als Vorbereiter zum 3:0 entstand
durch Julian alwades damit geht's für
Kroatien am Samstag um den dritten Platz
und für Messi am Sonntag um die Krönung
seiner Karriere um den WM
[Applaus]
und jetzt ein Mammutwerk in dieser
Sendung das im Kino zum historischen
Superlativ werden soll und irgendwie
wohl auch muss
Blockbuster Regisseur James Cameron
kehrt zurück in die Fabelwelt von Avatar
dem von ihm geschaffenen erfolgreichsten
Film aller Zeiten 2009 war das weltweite
Einnahmen fast 3 Milliarden Dollar es
war der große Auftritt von
atemberaubender 3D-Technik und dieser
kuriosen Mischung aus realen und
Computer animierten Elementen damals
ging es um anmutige blaue Wesen auf dem
Planeten Pandora ihre Heimat bedroht
durch die Gier der Menschen nach
Rohstoffen
seitdem ist es nicht unbedingt besser
geworden auf Pandora und auf der Erde
Zeit für eine Fortsetzung heute Abend
ist Premiere in Hollywood hier ist
Claudio Armbruster
wir müssen über Geld sprechen übers Geld
ausgeben und übers Geld einnehmen
sie möchten wirklich über Geld sprechen
sie haben diesen Film gesehen und
möchten über Geld sprechen natürlich
verspüre ich Druck immer ich mag Druck
unter Wasser zu sein ist auch eine
Abdruck
na gut tauchen wir erstmal ein wenn ihr
hier leben wollt
müsst ihr sie reiten lernen
im Kino und mit 3D Brille ist das ganze
natürlich beeindruckender Überwältigung
durch Bilder hergestellt durch
überwältigende Technik über drei Stunden
lang das geht schon in Richtung Wagner
Oper nur eben 250 Millionen Dollar
teurer
wichtig ist dass wir gewinnen machen
wenn das wird uns auch die Sicherheit
geben dass wir die Saga weitererzählen
können so ist das halt mit Filmen wenn
Marvel keinen Gewinn mit Ironman gemacht
hätte hätten sie keinen zweiten gedreht
beim Vergleich mit Kultfilmen wie Star
Wars oder Camerons Terminator und
Camerons Titanic fällt auf das vom
erfolgreichsten Film aller Zeiten Avatar
1 kaum etwas im kulturellen
weltgedächtnis hängengeblieben ist keine
ikonischen Szenen keine berühmten Zitate
kein arll be back oder kein ich bin dein
Vater und niemand trägt ein Avatar
Kostüm zu Karneval
auch aber Tag 2 hat nicht das Zeug zum
Kultfilm die Geschichte lässt sich in
drei Worten zusammenfassen Vater
beschützt Familie
ich will nur dass meine Familie sicher
ist thematisch gibt es von allem ein
bisschen
die Familie beschützen den Planeten
beschützen gerade heute
Krieg in der Ukraine Klimawandel
meiner Meinung nach wird das alles in
diesem Film gespielt
dies ist unser Zuhause
dies ist unsere Familie
hier leisten wir Widerstand wenn ein
Film viele Millionen Menschen erreichen
und Milliarden Dollar einspielen muss
dann muss er bildstark spannend und
Action geladen sein und die Geschichte
einfach vorhersehbar auf die 12 das kann
Hollywood und episch erzählten
Bilderrausch das kann Cameron
der Markt bestimmt wie viele Filme wir
machen werden vier wäre unser Plan vier
Teile sind schon geschrieben
die Schauspieler brauche ich nicht noch
mal
nun erstmal Avatar 2 ein modernes
Märchen und ein großes
multi-sinn-spektakel und wenn dann bei
the way of water auch the way of money
stimmt wird es Fortsetzungen geben Teil
3 4 5 und so weiter
so wir hatten so viel in der Sendung
dass wir jetzt noch Zeit haben zu sagen
wir wünschen Ihnen einen angenehmen
Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend das gefährlich weil dieser
Wetterlage ist dass auf diese Eiseskälte
hier im Alpenvorland heute gab es da
Höchsttemperaturen von nur minus 7 Grad
jetzt mildere Luft aus Südwesten trifft
10 Grad waren es in Frankreich und es
kommen Regenwolken heran und wenn dieser
Regen über die Eiseskälte am Boden zieht
dann wird es spiegelglatt in der zweiten
Nachthälfte geht es mit dem Glatteis
Regen los am Bodensee in Oberschwaben
und im Allgäu und bis zum frühen Morgen
erreicht der Glatteis Regen dann auch
München dann setzt neuer Glatteis Regen
hier von der Schweiz aus ein machen Sie
sich also auf gefährliche Glätte gefasst
im Süden von Baden-Württemberg und
Bayern und verschiebbare Wege die
vermeiden Sie morgen besser denn auch
über Tag bleibt es da sehr gefährlich
nördlich das Glatteis Regens fällt
Schnee 2 bis 10 cm können dadurch auch
zusammen kommen von all dem bekommen sie
in Norddeutschland so gut wie nichts mit
vielleicht reicht es mal für einen
Schneeschauer hier in Nordfriesland in
der Nacht die Temperatur und sinken in
den strengen Frost von -12 Grad hier im
Osten nicht ganz so eisig wird es im
Westen und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen meist knapp unter dem
Gefrierpunkt selten darüber nur am
Alpenrand da klettern die Werte bis
sechs Grad und das bedeutet am
Nachmittag fällt dann Regen in die Reste
von Glatteis und Schnee wenn es über
Stunden diesen Glatteisregen gibt dann
können sich richtige Eispanzer ausbilden
der Donnerstag wird deutlich ruhiger in
der Nacht zu Freitag und Freitag über
Tag schneit es dann schon wieder in
Süddeutschland guten Abend